[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANAND SHAH: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining me today.
My name is Anand Shah, and
I'm the product manager
on G Suite Marketplace.
So before we get
started, I really
want to talk about who you
guys are, just in case anyone
here is going through sort
of an identity crisis.
But more seriously, I want to
make sure everyone here gets
the most out of this session.
This session is
going to be focused
on G Suite admins looking to
really complement the G Suite
offering with all
the awesome tools
that our third-party
developers have built.
And so quickly going
over the agenda today,
we're going to talk about
picking the right SaaS
solution for your business and
what that process looks like.
And then we're going to
talk about how the G Suite
Marketplace can help.
Then we have two awesome
partners here, Smartsheet
and ProsperWorks.
We're going to talk through
their G Suite Marketplace apps
and how they can
empower your business.
And finally, we'll
leave some time for Q&A.
So let's get into it.
Let's talk about
picking the right SaaS
solution for your business
and how that process kind of
sucks right now.
So I'm going to talk
to you about a business
that I plan to open.
It's called Anand's
Beard Wax Corporation.
It doesn't exist right
now, but I promise you
I'm going to open
it when I retire,
and it's going to be awesome.
And the story of Anand's
Beard Wax Corporation
reflects a lot of the stories
that we hear from customers
today on G Suite.
Quick context--
we sell beard wax.
Also, I love this image
our designer produced,
because it kind of
looks more like me
than my original picture.
So we sell beard wax.
And our employees are
currently on G Suite.
They're using all the creative
tools on Docs, Sheets, Drive.
They're able to
collaborate, and they're
able to communicate on
Gmail and Hangouts and all
those sort of things.
But sales are skyrocketing.
We've run some ad campaigns
to all the hipster communities
in Brooklyn and San
Francisco, and everyone really
wants to style their
mustache, and the sales
are going through the roof.
And with all these
increased sales,
our employees need more tools.
We need tools to manage all
the sales and different leads.
We're getting a lot of
requests for bulk orders
of the beard wax.
We're getting a lot of
tickets from customers,
you know, good
feedback on how they're
able to style their
beards and mustaches,
but also some bad feedback on
all the rashes they're getting.
And we want to make sure we
get back to these customers
promptly.
And finally, we want to manage
all the different project
streams.
As we're updating
the website, as we're
developing new lines
of beard waxes,
we want to make
sure we can align
the marketing and the sales and
all the sort of production that
goes into that.
And as CEO of Anand's
Beard Wax Corporation,
it's a bit overwhelming.
So let's even talk about
one of these use cases.
Let's talk about
customer support
and what sort of factors go
into picking the right solution
for customer support.
I'm going to look at the price
for all the different tools
available.
Which one is the
cheapest, or which
one is going to run me dry?
Is the tool secure?
If all these tickets are
coming in from customers,
how do I make sure that
this data won't be leaked,
and that it won't show up
on the "New York Times?"
I want to make sure that
the tool that I pick
works with our company's
existing solutions,
especially with G Suite.
I want to make sure that the
tool works well with Gmail,
that all the files
coming in aren't
stored on a separate server
but are automatically in Drive.
And finally, I want to look
across all the different sort
of players in this
space, see what
other admins are
recommending, who is really
innovating in this space.
And then I also want to see
what my end users are using,
see if they already
have their own workflow
or are already using any
tools for customer support.
And so across all these factors,
it's, again, very overwhelming.
So let's talk about G
Suite Marketplace and sort
of how it can help.
So again, you have me as CEO of
Anand's Beard Wax Corporation,
and now I can go to the G Suite
Marketplace and sort of search
across all these different
categories of apps.
You know, there's accounting,
finance, HR, and legal.
And for all the apps that are
available on the Marketplace,
you can see a
description of the app
and also reviews and ratings
that other admins have left.
So where we're at now,
the G Suite Marketplace
has over 400 million installs,
and we have 1,000 apps.
And what I want everyone to
take away from this session
is that G Suite
Marketplace makes it easy.
It makes it easy to
discover a new app.
It makes it easy
to deploy the app.
And it makes it very easy to
control the different settings
on the app.
So let's get into discovery.
G Suite Marketplace makes it
easy to discover new apps.
I've already mentioned a
couple of these things before.
You can search across
different categories.
You can do a text-based
query for the app
that you're looking for.
We have tons of
ratings and reviews,
and curated sections for
different apps out there.
We have sections for what
works well with Drive, or what
works well--
what apps are new
and on the rise.
And we have a ton of
different categories across--
we have tools for finance
teams, tools for schools,
and even, like, if you think
about what Anand's Beard Wax
Corporation needed across
customer support, project
management, and sales
tools, we have all that sort
of stuff on the G
Suite Marketplace.
And so now I want to really
get into the specifics.
Like, what is an app
on G Suite Marketplace?
I like to think about it
in two different ways.
So one sort of category
of apps are add-ons.
These apps live inside
the UI of Google products.
As you can see on the
screenshot on the right,
we have an add-on directly
inside Google Docs.
This is Lucid Chart, and what
it lets users do is draw complex
charts-- whether it's
flow diagrams, org charts,
or floor plans--
directly in Google Docs.
So add-ons live inside
of the Google products,
and we have add-ons for Docs,
Sheets, Forms, and Drive.
And you guys might have seen,
over the last couple of days,
we've even announced upcoming
add-on support for Gmail,
Slides, and Hangouts Chat.
The other category
of apps that you'll
find on G Suite Marketplace
are your standard sort
of SaaS web apps.
You might go to
ProsperWorks.com,
Smartsheet.com, and these
sort of third-party apps
live on an external URL.
However, for all of
them, you can sign in
with your Google account.
And all of these apps also
use a lot of the Google APIs,
so you won't have to--
a lot of them will integrate
automatically with Drive,
will automatically
integrate with Calendar,
so you won't have to learn
a whole new system there.
So we talked about
discovery, how
you can find the app of your
dreams on G Suite Marketplace,
and all the different
types of apps available.
Let's talk about how you can
deploy an app from G Suite
Marketplace.
So I like to think of the
deployment in two ways.
If you're an admin,
you can actually
find the app that
you want to deploy,
and you can deploy it
to your entire company.
If I want everyone in my
company to use the same project
management tool, I can just
say I want to deploy this
to everyone at my company.
Or if it's a tool that's
specific for an organization--
a sales tool, you
might only want
to give to your sales folks.
If it's a customer
support tool, you
might only want to give
it to your support team.
And you can deploy it to a
specific organization as well.
Finally, you don't even
have to push out an app
to everyone in your domain.
Rather, you can let individuals
come to the G Suite Marketplace
and just install
whatever they want.
And so I want a
quick show of hands,
how many folks here have
seen this scary OAuth screen?
How many of you guys, when
you saw it, were like,
I don't know if I
should accept it,
or, like, sort of
freaked out about it?
No offense to
ProsperWorks, but here you
see ProsperWorks wants to
access your Drive and email.
And it's like, I don't
know if I should allow it.
How many folks have sort
of been like, I don't
know if I should accept it?
OK.
A couple.
We have sort of a
technical group here.
But what we've heard
from a lot of users
is that the end user
are freaked out when
they see this OAuth2 screen.
They're not sure if they should
give their company's access
to Gmail or Drive over
to a third-party app.
And what G Suite
Marketplace does
is it sort of transfers the
burden from the end user
to the admin.
So now an admin can
accept the OAuth2 grant
and bless it for
their entire domain,
so that when an end user
starts using ProsperWorks,
they don't sort of
see this screen.
And lastly, it's really
easy to deploy an app
on G Suite Marketplace.
Let's say here we
have Lucid Chart.
Not only do they have
a web app, but they
have a Sheets add-on, a Docs
add-on, and a Drive add-on.
Rather than having
to force everyone
to install each
one separately, you
can just deploy
all these add-ons
and go all in on Lucid
Chart with one click.
And finally, let's talk about
the different sort of tools
you have for control.
When end users go to
the G Suite Marketplace,
they can explore all the
different types of apps
that they want to start using.
However, we give
admins the ability
to sort of whitelist
certain apps
that they want the
end users to install.
So they can have the security
team audit different apps,
or just authorize certain
apps for people to install.
Finally, you can use G
Suite Marketplace to also
just deploy a custom app.
You know, if you've built an
internal project management
tool or internal sales
tool, you can also
use G Suite Marketplace to
push this out to your domain.
And so looking forward, we're
going to have more add-on types
in the future--
Gmail, Slides, Hangouts
Chat, Hangouts Chatbots
are all coming soon.
We're updating our store
UI, going all material.
And we're going to have enhanced
administrative features.
So you can-- this is coming
soon, but a lot of admins,
like, maybe they don't
want their end users
to start using apps that have
access to Drive or have access
to Gmail.
So you can start
blacklisting and whitelisting
different OAuth2 scopes.
And I want to give a quick
shout-out to our recommended
partners on G Suite.
A lot of these folks have made
G Suite Marketplace really
successful, and a
lot of customers
have seen success using
these partners' apps.
So I think a lot of them have
booths on the first floor,
so if you haven't had a
chance, go check them out.
And with that, I
just want to recap.
G Suite Marketplace makes
it easy to discover the app
that you want to
use at your company
and easily deploy
it at your company.
And then finally, just control
all the settings around it.
And with that, I'm
going to hand it off
to Andy Lientz from Smartsheet.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDY LIENTZ: Good afternoon.
Thanks for coming out today.
I want to just spend a little
time introducing Smartsheet,
but then talk about how
important the Google
partnership and the Google apps
are for us and for our users
today.
So we live in a space where
project management has kind of
been left to the 2% of the
people that understand project
management principles.
And as we understand,
calendaring and other stuff
were that way five years ago.
So as the work is
transforming, Smartsheet
provides 18,000 new
processes or projects
to their users every day.
So it's a growing
world where people
realize that they
don't have a tool to do
the things they need to do.
So what we are is
collaborative work management.
Collaborative work management
basically comes to this place
where we had project management
software in the past,
but we were really using
Excel, or spreadsheets,
and email to solve a
problem which was, I
got to gather data from people.
We got to talk about it.
We got to share it.
We got to go through it.
But then we didn't
do anything with it.
We sort of were
dead-ended there.
And now the number of apps
where that's happening,
whether it's sort of legacy
IT apps or other apps
that people are using,
is increasing in volume.
And then the number of places
that they are connecting,
whether that's all
through G Suite or 100
other products that
are all best of breed,
is increasing as well.
So the number of
vectors that you
have to cover for all of your
users is going up as well.
And so as we look at
this place-- and this
is happening now because
users are doing more stuff all
the time online.
The velocity is going up.
So we're living in a world
where these three V's
are causing us, as
administrators or as developers
or whichever audience we're
in, to have to deal with this.
But in order for our users
to be delighted and actually
want to come to
work every day, we
have to provide them
with great tools.
And the great tools
have to work together.
So these are some of our stats
over the Google partnership
that we've had,
and we've enjoyed
a really strong partnership with
them for the last four years.
But I want to talk a
little more about what
the important thing is.
So Anand talked
about picking an app.
And so when you go to pick an
app in the modern workforce,
we really believe
that you need to pick
something that's usable by
all teams in the company.
So it's not enough to just
deploy a project management
solution and hope your
five project managers can
cover your 200-person company.
You have to cross boundaries.
You have to be able to share
internally and externally.
You have to integrate
all key apps.
And everybody has
to be satisfied.
That means security
needs to be there.
That means your control
But at the same time, you
really have to show users
that they have a product
they can use every day,
so that you empower
them to be better.
So what I wanted to do before I
talked any more, because people
are like, what's Smartsheet
and what's project management?
We put together a little video
about how we work with G Suite,
so you guys could kind of see
a real-world example that we
do for our users every day.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SPEAKER 1: Smartsheet
is the leading SaaS
platform for managing and
automating collaborative work.
Thousands of the world's
most productive companies
and millions of
information workers
trust Smartsheet to
help them work better.
Smartsheet's
scalable platform is
easy to use and configure for
a variety of high-value use
cases.
Smartsheet is recommended
for G Suite and integrates
with Google apps and services.
To see this in
action, let's look
at how a company uses
Smartsheet in Google
to accelerate service delivery
and delight customers.
Luke manages a sales team.
He has a forecast review
meeting later today,
so he checks his pipeline
sheet to prepare.
Luke sees he's at risk
of missing his forecast
because a new services
engagement hasn't been assigned
yet and isn't included in
his numbers for the quarter.
He assigns the
project to Jeanette,
and makes sure the services
delivery takes place
before the end of the quarter.
Luke's sheet
automatically publishes
the delivery dates
to Google Calendar
for additional visibility
into the deal's timing.
Jeanette receives an
email notification
about the new
assignment and logs
in to Smartsheet with her Google
account to view the details.
She sees that the project
has a tight timeline,
and immediately starts a
Hangout with Chris, the services
engineer, to get
more information.
Chris responds and updates
Jeanette with information
from a recent customer call
about the scope of the work.
He also attaches a PDF
of the SOW document
he saved in Google Drive
to the project sheet
so that everyone working on
the project can access it.
Jeanette ends her
Hangout with Chris
and updates the project status.
Mike, the VP of sales,
reviews his team's performance
and sees his team is rocking
and ahead of plan, making him
and his customer a fan for life.
[END PLAYBACK]
ANDY LIENTZ: That is real.
No, it's not real.
But to that point, you saw a
lot of integrations in there.
It goes through quickly,
but we have over 15 points
of integration with G Suite.
And part of us being in
the G Suite Marketplace
and really being
a recommended app,
we believe that it's important
for all of our Google users
to be able to work
with us every day.
And as you noticed, that
was a seamless workflow
through the organization
where you dropped in and out
of different tools,
through Gmail and Calendar,
but nobody needed to know
that what was happening
was that Smartsheet was
behind the scenes driving
some of the work automation
and work management.
So to that end, I
wanted to talk about how
we think about this space.
So traditionally,
project management
has been sort of to
the single person.
And as we look at process
management and work
automation and
the things that we
used to always do by
emailing around spreadsheets,
there's a bunch of things
that we can make better,
and that's by doing
better tracking.
And so today we have that with
Gmail for our contact lists.
We can start a Hangout
directly from Smartsheet.
We can report better,
so we can actually
merge info from Smartsheet
to power a mail merge
in Docs for a small business.
So if you have
somebody that says,
hey, I have an address list.
It's in a spreadsheet.
Import it from Sheets, use
the mail merge functionality,
and you generate a
bunch of documents.
It's a fairly simple integration
that can be done every day.
Then, on the automation front,
we can bring data directly
from Sheets into
Smartsheet, and we
can send updated
requests via Gmail
and fill them out in a form.
We also do single sign-on.
We're working right now on skim,
so you can do user provisioning
and deprovisioning
directly from Google.
And you can create and attach
and view sheets to Google Drive
and restrict it to
Google Drive so that you
can get full management
capability throughout the app
from Google and
using Smartsheet.
So it becomes a very
easy way for you
to control the data
that goes in there,
and you have a lot of
controls for it coming out.
But at the same time, the
users get a seamless experience
with both Smartsheet
and working with Google.
I guess I can go back to--
So one of the big
customers that we had
was a sort of former
Microsoft Project customer
and migrated over to Google.
And today, they're actually
a large-scale manufacturing
software business.
But essentially, they came by
and said, with Google apps,
with Workday, and
with Smartsheet,
we have transformed our entire
business from a legacy stack.
So eliminated
Microsoft Project that
was a hole in
their marketplace--
or a hole in their operation
after they flipped over,
but also to do
other things which
throughout human resources,
finances, and sales,
they're using us every
day from employee
onboarding to actual
tracking of their sales team.
So it really allows a powerful
work management experience
throughout the app, but
again, it does all this stuff
while working with
the Google apps
that they're using every day.
So the learning curve gets
smaller and the deployment
gets easier.
So as we talk about transforming
work is a very lofty solution,
one of the things that we've
been talking a lot about
is that we have to
empower everybody
to do automation and
do process and get
to those things on their own.
And as you guys have
a large user base,
you have a set of people that
you're supporting every day,
it's really
important to remember
that they are not technical.
And so we're throwing more and
more apps at them every day,
and every time they have
to learn a new paradigm.
And that's great when it's
Snapchat and Facebook and it's
fun to do on your phone.
It's not great when you
have to come to work
and you can't get
your work done.
And so it's really important
that we do that and continue
to do that.
We have more intelligence
now today with AI
and powering those things, so
we should make our apps better.
And the thing that I
keep telling people
is we did a user study
recently, and our users
said, when the word
"if" appeared on screen,
that it was too programmer-y.
It was too hard to use the
word "if" in a construct.
They wanted the word "when."
And the reason I bring that
up is all these developers,
and everybody else, is saying,
I can teach these people
to be citizen developers!
But I think that's
the wrong thing.
I think we need to support
them in using lots of apps,
and I think we need to do
it to make work better.
So what I'm hoping, and what I'm
hoping more people in the room
sort of attach to
and build for, is
let's agree to
delight our users,
whether that's giving
them the apps they want
or managing the apps so
they don't see what's
going on behind the scenes.
Let's get apps to talk together
without copy and paste.
One of our biggest use
cases for Dashboard
is the elimination
of PowerPoint,
because what people want to
see is real-time dashboards
of projects, and they don't
want to copy and paste them
out of a spreadsheet that they
roll up, that they put in there
and spend an hour each week.
So find the things
that you can do
to support your users every
day so they can spend less time
doing those sorts of things.
And then, find the
things that they
don't know they don't know.
So as we talk about all
this artificial intelligence
and other things that we can
use to support our users,
let's use AI to make
their life better,
not let's use our AI to surface
10 times more information.
And so my challenge to
all of these people that
are supporting all their
customers every day
is let's make work
better not because we
have a lot more
technology, but let's
make it better so that
people are more effective.
And so to that end, we've
announced at this conference
that we are working on
the Hangouts Chat, which
is the Hangouts v2 to go with
our Hangouts v1 integration.
We're also looking at Google Now
to make it easier to input data
into our system.
And at the same
time, we're going
to invest heavy in
machine learning,
not to sort of predict
where people are going,
but to help them find the
features that they don't have.
And so as we look forward to
innovation, as we look forward
to doing more things with
Google and supporting you guys
and building better
products, we really
look to making a great
product, but using
the power of technology
and innovating on the way
our users can consume it.
It needs to be much easier for
users to do the hard things
that we want them to do, so
they can be more effective.
So if you want to see us,
we'll be down at booth D2.
Joe's the manager of
our Google alliance.
We've got other
folks down there.
Feel free to come
by, get a demo,
or just sort of learn a
little more about Smartsheet.
And there's-- thank you.
And I'm handing it
off to ProsperWorks.
[APPLAUSE]
KIRA LENKE: Thank you, Andy.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Kira Lenke, and I'm here
with my colleague Jesse Price.
And we are with
ProsperWorks, which
is a CRM that's
purpose-built for G Suite.
We're super excited
to be here today.
The event has been
awesome, and we're
thrilled to have the
opportunity to tell you
guys a little bit
about ProsperWorks
and how we're helping our
customers be more successful.
But first, I want to address
a question that I think--
yes, the clicker-- that I
think some of you have had,
either consciously
or subconsciously,
as I've been talking
today, which is--
oh, here we go--
really, another CRM?
There's a lot of CRMs out there.
We know.
So what could possibly be so
great, or so unique, or so
different, about ProsperWorks?
So I think that's a
really valid question.
And I want to spend a
few minutes answering it
for you guys and telling
you why we're here
and the problem that we're
really trying to solve.
So when you ask people
about their experience
with their CRM, you typically
don't get any warm and fuzzies.
They're not positive responses.
You get people that are really
frustrated, saying things like,
I hate it.
It's a pain in
the you-know-what.
It's clunky.
It's way too complicated.
It really doesn't
help me do my job
any better or faster or easier.
It honestly just requires
a boatload of work and time
and effort for me,
and I really don't
feel like I'm getting
anything in return.
And so because of that,
people just don't use it.
And that's a really big problem.
It's a problem
because your CRM--
every business needs a CRM.
It's a mission-critical
tool for your business,
and it's not just there
to collect all your data
and manage all of your
contacts in one place.
It's there to really give
you visibility and insights
and the data you
need to make smarter
decisions that will help you
move your business forward.
And if people aren't
using your CRM,
you're not going to get any
of that value out of it.
So that's the problem
that we are solving.
We're building-- we've built--
a CRM that actually gives
users more than it takes.
We're building a CRM that is
really, really easy to use.
So not only your team will use
it, but when they're using it,
they love using it.
They want to use it.
And we're doing it by removing
all the things that really suck
about all the other CRMs,
which is manual data entry,
and annoying, tedious,
repetitive tasks that
are super time-consuming.
And we're making it super
intuitive and beautiful
and really easy to use.
And we're integrating
it with the tools
that you already know and
love, so that it's seamlessly
a part of your existing
processes and workflow.
So we're solving a really,
really hard problem
that no CRM has been
able to solve before,
which is the adoption
and usability problem.
And we think Google
agrees with our approach.
So we are the number-one
recommended CRM
in the G Suite Marketplace.
We won Google's best new
technology last year.
We're the first partner to
build on Google's Slides API.
And we're one of
the first people
who were able to build
the Gmail add-on that
was announced yesterday,
which is very exciting.
And even some of Google's
teams are actually
using ProsperWorks,
which is awesome.
So it's not just Google
that's validated this problem
that we're solving and
agrees with us that this
is something important.
We have 75,000 users
who love ProsperWorks.
And I'm going to pass
it over to Jesse,
who's going to tell
you how they're
using ProsperWorks and the
value that we're providing them
today.
JESSE PRICE: Great.
Thanks, Kira.
And thanks for
attending the session.
Excited to be here today.
So I've got a great job.
I'm the director of
sales at ProsperWorks,
and that means that I get
to spend a lot of time
with our customers,
understanding their businesses
and really helping them kind
of solve this CRM challenge.
And just to echo what Kira
has been speaking about,
I don't know when,
but at some point,
CRM just got really hard.
You know, it became
really complex.
It gives the users
anxiety when they
think about logging in
and making their updates.
And so people just don't use it.
And so from a
product standpoint,
you know, at ProsperWorks,
we really think
about that CRM
journey, really getting
control of your customer
data in a few different ways.
Number one, it's helping
teams become hyperorganized,
knowing where data is, having
easy access to that data,
being able to follow up
on time with every lead
and make the most of that.
And number two is
once you're organized,
it's really about being able
to establish those processes
in your business that make it
super easy for maybe a new rep
to follow, or someone who's
not as well-versed with sales
process, really kind of take
your behaviors, the senior A
players, make it super easy
for the rest of the team
to follow those.
And then the last part is
really having the insights
to optimize those
processes over time.
So you want to constantly
improve your business
and make sure that every
quarter, every year, you're
doing better.
So one of our
customers, Peugeot,
who's a French car manufacturer
you may have heard of,
had this exact
problem with adoption
among some of their dealers
in one of their Asia offices,
where people were not
using their existing CRM,
reverting to paper notes,
sticky notes, spreadsheets,
which is really not helpful
from a company standpoint,
having visibility of
what people are talking
about with their customers,
and means that a lot of people
aren't following up as well,
because they kind of lose
these pieces of
paper and so forth.
So we migrated them to G
Suite with one of our partners
in the Asia region, and put
CRM right inside of Gmail.
So using a Chrome extension
that we built really closely
with Google, it would
basically take your CRM data
and put it right in front
of where your users spend
the majority of their time,
which is inside of Gmail,
Calendar, and other Google G
Suite applications like Sheets,
and Slides, Hangouts,
and so forth.
So we're able to
basically give you
context over that last
interaction that you
had with the customer, or maybe
give you the contact details
that you need to reach
out, so that you're
making updates in
real time and not
being sort of asked to then log
in to a different application
and kind of make those changes
at the end of the day, which
let me tell you, a lot
of people just don't do.
So in terms of that
context and accessibility
to your CRM
information, we think
it's really important
to have that in Gmail,
but it's also really
important to have
that on your cell phone.
We carry these things
everywhere that we go,
and being able to make
those updates from the road
is really important.
And I think that our
customer Local Roots has
a really great example of that.
So what these guys do is they've
pioneered a way to essentially
grow a food farm inside of
a shipping container, which
is pretty cool.
They're solving the world's
food shortage problems
using these really innovative,
highly mobile farms that
can produce a lot of
food really quickly.
And they coordinate
these deliveries
from a few satellite
offices around the world
with a highly mobile workforce.
And with mobile apps,
they're able to quickly make
updates, when they're in an
Uber or if they're on their way
to the airport,
waiting for a plane,
and have real-time information
about these shipments
and deliveries right
there in their pocket.
And as Kira mentioned
before, something else
that is really exciting
from a mobile standpoint
is that we are now able to
integrate CRM data straight
into your Gmail app on your
phone through the Gmail add-on
that we announced yesterday.
We also have another mobile
add-on for Google Sheets,
so that I can
refresh my sales data
from inside of my Google Sheets
app from my cell phone as well.
And I really think this
is exciting for the future
of mobile apps,
where they're not
just standalone
applications anymore,
but they're integrated and
able to tie in together.
So just to recap, talking
about organization
being really important,
having access to data,
the next step is really
creating those processes,
so looking at your A
players on your team
and being able to
make a path that
is really easy for the
other people in the company
to follow to get
the same results.
So we use very visual pipelines.
What you can see in
the graphic there
is that it's really clean.
We've used material design
across all of our platforms,
be it web, mobile, the Chrome
extension, you name it.
So it makes it really easy
for people to adopt and learn
how to use the CRM.
In this example-- the
reason I like this example
is that our customer
Love Your Melon are not
a sales organization.
They're a not-for-profit who
are selling beanies, mittens,
other clothing items, and
using all of those proceeds
to really contribute to
an important cause, which
is battling cancer among
children in the US.
And so they use these pipelines
not for a sales process,
but to essentially coordinate
really complex recruiting
events on university
campuses around the States.
And it really is easy for those
sort of non-technical college
students to follow
the process that's
laid out in front of them, to
organize these great events.
Now, once your team's
organized and following
the right processes,
as I mentioned before,
it's really important
to constantly improve
your business and be able
to tweak and optimize
these processes over time.
And so we have a
really easy-to-use set
of reports in the system
that don't require
you to hire a business
analyst or know how to create
really complex queries.
It's all very visual, very
kind of drag and drop,
click-orientated, if you will,
so that any business user can
really embrace that data
and look for opportunities
to improve those outcomes.
So eShares are a really
great fintech start-up
in the Bay Area that
are growing like crazy.
And they just brought on
a new VP of sales, Ben,
who we work closely with.
And you know, the feedback we
got from Ben, that he was just
blown away about
really quickly was
how easy it is to
adapt ProsperWorks
to his sales process,
and not ask his team
to adapt to the CRM.
And that was really
important for them,
because when he came on board,
they were using a legacy CRM.
Obviously, no one was really
keeping the data up to date,
and so as a new VP of sales,
very difficult to build a sales
plan, understand how many
people he should be hiring
and in what time frame.
So if this all sounds
really great to you guys,
and you're kind of
interested in thinking,
like, well, that's cool, but
what's it take to set up?
I've tried
implementing CRM before
and it's really difficult.
It's really expensive.
And it was a failure.
Rest assured, just like the
rest of our kind of design
philosophy and ease of
use, getting started
is super easy as well.
So what we're able to
do is, when you log in
through your Gmail
account, we can basically
analyze your inbox and
start to suggest people
that you may want to
add to the system based
on the patterns
of email activity
that you've had with
these people in the past.
So it's great because it
surfaces the right data
for your organization.
You're not kind of forced
to ship in a pile of data
from a system that
wasn't working previously
and move those problems
to a new platform.
What's also great is that
when you add these people
to the system, we're going to go
out and research them for you,
so we'll find things
like their company
information, how many
employees they have,
where they're located.
Let's give you some links
to their social profiles
so you can go and see
what's relevant to them
and what they've
been tweeting about.
And that saves our
users tons of time.
So if you look at a
sales team of 30, 40,
50 people all going out and
collecting that information
on a per-contact basis,
this is a massive time-saver
and a really great
experience for the user when
they are sort of surprised and
delighted by the information
we can surface for them.
Now, in addition to getting
your data into the system,
all the configuration is
basically clicks and not code,
so that you don't have to reach
out to an expensive consultant,
as you may have been used
to doing in the past,
to get started.
We've got a team who
can help with that.
And we really want to empower
you as the business user
to be able to make
these administration
changes without having to
once again make a phone call
and wait a week in order
to update a custom field
or to tweak your sales process
based on something that's
happening in the marketplace.
So to recap, in our view,
CRM is about helping
teams be hyperorganized,
helping your teams follow up,
having access to data from
within the apps that you're
already using today, which is
things like Gmail, Calendar,
Sheets, Slides, having
access on your mobile apps,
and sort of the
integration of now
your G Suite applications and
applications like ProsperWorks
from a mobile
standpoint as well,
being able to implement process
that anybody can follow,
regardless of how well-versed
they are in CRM or in business
process management themselves,
just make it very visual,
very easy to engage with.
And then finally, having
those analytics and insights
to really improve those
processes as a business,
and make sure that your results
are always getting better.
So back to you, Kira.
KIRA LENKE: Great.
Cool.
So we've been talking at you
guys for, like, 10 minutes now.
So if there's anything
we want you to take away
from hearing from
Jesse and I, it's
that ProsperWorks is a CRM that
teams actually love to use,
and it's because it's
purpose-built for G Suite.
It sits right in your inbox.
It's super intuitive.
It works on any device.
And you can get up and
running in a matter of days
or even hours.
So if you're interested
in learning more,
you can visit us downstairs
in booth E2 today,
or of course, you can go to
our website, prosperworks.com.
Thanks for listening.
And I'm going to
invite Anand back up
to give some final parting
words before we dig in
to the Q&A session.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ANAND SHAH: You guys
need this to stay up?
Cool.
We'll jump right into Q&A,
but just final call to action,
go visit G Suite Marketplace,
gsuite.google.com,
or there's a nifty
tool called Google.
Just search G Suite Marketplace.
[MUSIC PLAYING]